>> It's a pleasure to introduce
the presenters this evening.
Dan Rothstein is Co-Director of
The Right Question Institute.
He is Co-Author with Luz
Santana of Make Just One Change,
Teach Students to Ask Their
Own Questions, the book,
which first introduced the
Question Formulation Technique.
Dan's work focuses on honoring and
supporting the work of 200,000 educators
who are driving a movement in urban, suburban
and rural communities to help students learn
to ask better questions and take
more ownership of their own learning.
Dan has a Doctorate from Harvard, The
Harvard Graduate School of Education.
And Andrew P. Minigan is The Right
Question Institute's Education Project
and Research Coordinator.
He leads the search on Templeton Foundation
Funded Million Classrooms Campaign which aims
to nurture student curiosity and cultivate
critical thinking skills through the use
of the Question Formulation
Technique in one million classrooms.
Andrew has an Education Masters in
Human Development and Psychology
from The Harvard Graduate School of Education.
Welcome Dan and Andrew, and take it away.
>> I would just like to thank the Library
of Congress for this great opportunity.
And we have Twitter and please
feel free to follow us.
We offer many resources and materials
on our website, www.RightQuestion.org.
And this helps support the work of
the educators who are using the QFT.
We'd also like to thank the search on
Templeton Foundation and the Hummingbird Fund
for the support of the Million
Classrooms Campaign.
And again, I'd like to thank the Library of
Congress for inviting us to do this webinar.
And I'd like to now introduce Dan who will
be sharing how this work began and the start
of the work in Lawrence, Massachusetts.
>> Great to be here.
Tonight we'll have a, a chance to look
at addressing the fundamental challenge
in education that students
are not asking questions,
a chance to experience the
Question Formulation Technique,
see examples of classroom
use and students questions.
We'll have a chance to identify the value
of teaching students to ask questions,
and reflect on different ways to use
the Question Formulation Technique.
Our work began more than 20
years ago when Luz Santana and I
and several other people were
working in Lawrence, Massachusetts.
And we learned from parents, that we were
working on dropout prevention program.
And our role was to try to engage more parents
to participate in their children's education.
And the parents told us, we don't go to the
schools because we don't even know what to ask.
So we thought we had a solution to that.
We could come up with a list of questions.
But what they actually named was a more
fundamental problem, is that the ability
to ask one's own questions, to know how
to organize your thinking around things
that you're not familiar with, that you
don't know, is really the key challenge.
So what we really needed to do was relaying
to look at how do we teach that skill.
So we began our work, working with parents, and
ASCD recently published a book on our strategy
for working with parents to get them
more involved as partners with educators
and in children's education, we
also began to work in healthcare
and we saw a National Institute's of Health
Study that showed a doubling and tripling
of patient activation engagement when they
used the Question Formulation Technique.
We, it began to be noticed by
people in the private sector,
in Warren Berger's book,
A More Beautiful Question.
He featured the strategy as
a way to promote innovation.
And we also began to use the strategy with
border engagement efforts for people to begin
to learn to ask questions about
decisions and elections that affect them.
So we began to then hear from other people
who were also acknowledging the significance
of the importance of learning
to ask your own questions.
And Stuart Firestein, a professor at Columbia
University wrote a beautiful book called
Ignorance How it Drives Science.
And he said that his graduate students
come in, they see a 1400 page textbook
and they think that's all that there is to know.
But actually, he said, that
simply is what we know.
What we don't know is much greater.
So our students really need to
learn how to think in questions.
How to manage ignorance.
College presidents were asked by New York
Times, what should students learn in college?
Leon Botstein said, of Bard
College, of Bard College said,
the primary skills should be analytical
skills of interpretation inquiry.
In other words, know how to frame a question.
Nancy Cantor, at the time the Chancellor of the
University of Illinois said, the best we can do
for students is to have them
ask the right questions.
What do college students say about what
they learned in school, in college?
Barely a quarter of them say
that they really learned,
that they were taught how
to ask their own questions.
The problem clearly begins long before college.
So take a moment and look at this slide here.
You see a generally upward slope of basic
skill attainment and reading and writing.
There's still a lot of work
to keep it moving further up,
but you see a generally upward slope.
Now look at this next slide.
That yellow line is the line of asking
questions, and you see a general decline
from the age of four, just about when students
are entering school, and it declines all the way
down to maybe a quarter of
students actively asking questions
by the time they finish high school.
So our work, and the work
that we can do together is
on changing the direction of that slope.
And we're not alone.
There are more than 200,000 educators
around the world now using the strategy
of the Question Formulation Technique
that we will explore in-depth tonight,
and they're doing that without any mandate
or requirement because it solves a problem
that they see in front of them
every day, and that's the problem
that we're going to work on together.
So what happens when students
learn to ask their own questions?
Well John Hedy's research shows that
self-questioning is a metacognitive strategy,
improves students rate of
learning by nearly 50%.
This is a very significant gain
and very significant indication
of how important the skill is.
Students questions then serve as a catalyst
for their curiosity, for greater engagement,
for more ownership of their learning,
and it leads to deeper learning.
And what do students say?
Students talk about, just when you
think you know all you need to know,
you ask another question and discover
how much more there is to learn.
That's what a sixth grade student said
in California, that sense of discovery.
Now here's another student who's in
a, a high school in Boston who said,
when you ask the question you feel
like it's your job to get the answer.
So imagine that.
Imagine you have your students in
front of you, and they're excited
because they've discovered another question
they, they discover how much more there is
to learn, exactly what Professor Firestein
at Columbia University had mentioned.
And then you have a student who says, he
feels like it's his job to get the answer.
Think about what that would mean if, if your
students were feeling that all the time.
Students, in this process of the, using
the Question Formulation Technique learn
to produce their own questions,
learn to improve their questions,
strategize on how to use their questions,
and learn to reflect on what they've learned.
So now we're going to take a
moment to have a quick exercise
in the Question Formulation Technique.
It's your turn.
So we're going to start with basic
rules for producing questions.
And look at these our rules.
Ask as many questions as you can, do
not stop to answer, judge or discuss,
write down every question exactly as stated,
and change any statements into questions.
Those are four rules we often ask
people to spend a little time thinking
about what might be difficult
about following these rules.
People have a good discussion and they
think about what might be difficult,
but they're all set to, to follow the rules.
And then we ask, okay which rule
are you going to violate first.
And people kind of laugh and they get,
then they realize that they're going
to have trouble not stopping to
answer, judge or discuss them.
And so they kind of are aware that
these can be difficult to follow.
But for the purpose of our exercise we're
going to ask you to do the best you can
on your own to be following these rules.
So here's your focus.
Some students are not asking
good historical questions.
What are your questions about that?
As you're, as you're sitting there
thinking, ask as many questions as you can.
Don't edit yourself, just get them down there.
I have to tell you this is a very painful
thing for me to ever have to cut anybody off
from asking questions, but I got to do it,
we've got a time, we've got a time limit.
So we're going to move on.
I want you to get through the whole process.
There's a lot more coming,
a lot of good things coming.
Okay. So now let's take a moment and
look at closed and open ended questions.
Close ended questions can be answered with
a yes or a no, or the one word answer.
And open ended questions
require more explanation.
What I'd like you to do is to think
about the questions that you asked,
and identify some close ended ones and
some close ended, and open ended ones.
So let's move on to the next step.
Think for a moment about close ended questions.
What are some advantages
of close ended questions?
Now let's think for a moment
about close ended questions
and what are some disadvantages
to close ended questions?
So we're going to move on to the next step.
Let's look at open ended questions.
What are some advantages
to open ended questions?
And what are some disadvantages
Okay so we're going to move on
to the next step because there's,
there's more to share, more to learn.
So let's take a moment and take one of your
close ended questions, take any of the ones
that you've seen, a close ended question,
change it into an open ended question.
And take one open ended question and
change it into a close ended question.
Okay. So let's move on now to
the next step in the process.
We produce questions following, using
four rules to produce lots of questions.
Then you began to look more
closely at your questions and look
at closed and open and open and closed.
And you practiced changing
from one kind to the other.
And now let's move on to the next step here.
Let's take a look at questions that you have,
and choose two questions that strike you
as that you consider most important.
And while prioritizing and
thinking about those two questions,
think about the original
question focus that I gave you,
some students are not asking
good historical questions.
So let's see if we can get
questions in a question form,
two questions that you consider most important.
Okay. There's a lot going on here.
Again, I can't tell you how
much pain this brings me to have
to cut off this great thinking,
but we're going to continue
to do thinking together but on to the next step.
So let me take you to the next step
after you've prioritized the questions.
I want you to think for a moment
about why you chose those questions
as your priority questions, and to think about,
in this case you don't have the
entire sequence in front of you.
But think about you know you may have a sense
of when, in the original list of questions,
did that priority question come from.
Was it the beginning, was it
the middle, towards the end?
Just if you have some sense of
that, why don't you share that.
Why did you choose the priority questions
that you chose, and where did they come
from in that, in your original list?
Okay. So there's a lot of, of analysis here
and reflection on where did they come from,
and explained the rationale for choosing them.
And getting a sense of where they came
from, from the original work with questions.
So let's move on to the next step.
We're going to move into reflection.
And what I'd like you to do now is to stop
for a moment, and think about in this exercise
in which produced questions, you worked
on changing and improving your questions,
and you prioritized your questions and you
thought about why you choose those questions
and where they came from, what did
you learn, and how did you learn it.
So what we're going to do now is we're going
to take a quick peak inside the black box.
The Question Formulation Technique had
several components so let's take a quick look
at what actually happens when
you go through that process.
So the real contribution of the Question
Formulation Technique to student learning
and to pedagogy is that there are three
thinking abilities with one process.
And you start with the rules for producing
questions that allow students to do something
that very often is one of the
most difficult things for them
to do, and that is divergent thinking.
They may come up with one idea, one question,
and then shrug their shoulder
and say that's all I got.
But the rules create space and
allow for students to begin
to push themselves to produce more questions.
That divergent taking a step is really
critical for helping them begin to open
up different pathways of thinking.
But it doesn't stop there, because when
the students start to move into looking
at their open and close ended questions and
how to change them, they very often discover
that the way you ask a question can
yield different kinds of information.
Now that's a huge discovery.
So they're beginning to become
more sophisticated thinkers.
They're understand, more
sophisticated question askers.
But it doesn't stop there.
Then they go on to prioritize their questions,
and in prioritizing very often they discover,
they discover that they can't answer question
number two, the second question that came up,
until they've answered question number nine.
And then they realize that
they have never before
in their lives come up with nine questions.
And actually having done
that work led to a question
that they understood was very
important that they needed to address.
So this is another major discovery.
But it doesn't stop at convergent
thinking either.
There's another thinking ability that is going
on when they're using a question formulation
technique and that's metacognition.
Because from the very outset we would
start off by asking students to think
about what might be difficult
in following the rules.
And the discussion that you would hear from
that is always very interesting as they,
as they realize that there are different
pieces of that or asking them to act in a way
that they're not necessarily accustomed
doing, which is hearing a question
and asking another question, rather than
stopping to answer it or discuss it.
So that metacognition starts at the very
beginning, it continues when they're thinking
about open and closed, advantages and
disadvantages of both kinds of questions.
That's a new way of thinking about it.
It continues when they're
asked to explain the rationale
for why they choose their priority questions.
And of course it concludes with a
reflection where students get to do something
that they rarely have an opportunity to do,
which is to name what they learned by working
with their own questions, and to think
about how they learned what they learned.
So this is a really amazing
process that allows students
to become very sophisticated question askers
and thinkers, in a very short period of time.
So what we have seen is example after example.
It's been so inspiring and exciting and
even from last year's webinar we had people
who participated in, in this webinar last
year, who went off and did great things
with the Question Formulation Technique.
And this was the source for, for
them going off and doing that.
And we have continued to learn from the
great work that's begin done in the field.
So we're going to share with
you now some classroom examples
so that you can see what teachers
and students are doing with this.
The first one is an example of, from
Joshua Beers eighth grade history class
in Lempster, New Hampshire.
And the topic was American Imperialism.
And he used the Question Formulation Technique
for a very special purpose,
for summative assessment.
His question focus that he presented to his
class, and the class was already experienced
in using the Question Formulation Technique
so they already were very skilled at it.
And they had already done a whole unit
on American Imperialism at
the end of the 20th Century.
So his question focus was simply
questions that should be asked
about American Imperialism at
the turn of the 20th Century.
And let's look at some of
their priority questions.
Number two, why did the Hawaiian Natives
in Queen Liliuokalani not want
the United States to annex Hawaii?
Very specific fact related to the end of 20th,
at the end of the 19th Century
American Imperialism.
Look at, look at number ten, how did
the Spanish American War affect America?
Very, an interesting question
that about a specific event.
But then looking at what its impact is.
And then look at the question that's listed
there, number 12, which actually was connected
to the original question number six, and
was one that they changed in the process.
So it didn't even exist on their
original list of questions.
And it was, why did Alfred Thayer Mahan
have the stance that he did on Imperialism?
So they are looking at basically
the, one of the intellectual leaders
in the, around the idea of Imperialism.
And they were able to, to look at,
at his work and say, this is a,
a question that somebody who's knowledgeable
about American Imperialism
should be able to answer.
So there is a lot of work done
just with their questions.
Now let's take a quick look at the, an
example from his classroom that's an excerpt
from a video that's on our website, and is also
in an article that we wrote that Andrew and,
and Luz wrote for Educational
Leadership last year.
We're going to take a look at a classroom
example from Maureen Bennett, Lexington,
Massachusetts, third grade history
unit on the Mayflower compact.
And it's an introduction to unit on Pilgrims.
So here's her question focus.
Maureen presented them with
the Mayflower compact.
They were looking at it individually
on their iPads.
And they spent some time reading it.
And then they got to work asking questions.
And they asked some very specific questions
about words that were in the compact.
Then look at question number five.
Did the Indians sign it?
So that was their first question that,
that they changed from closed to open.
To they changed it from did the Indians
sign it to how many Indians sign it.
Then look at the next question
that that provoked.
Did the Pilgrims sign it?
They decided to change that as well.
Who signed it?
And then they asked this question very
specific to the compact and who is Lord James,
and they changed that as well, was
Lord James asking what is furtherance.
So, so they really did an, an interesting
prioritization here, and they got to questions
that were very significant and related to
issues of, of autonomy and, and participation,
and collective agreement, and thinking
about who might agree, who might not agree,
who might sign it, who might not sign it.
So there was a lot of very
sophisticated thinking that was going on,
by looking at this very difficult text.
I should tell you what Maureen
said, is that what she said is
after they asked those questions at the
beginning of the unit, she was struck how
that year the students kept on discovering,
as they moved further ahead in this,
is oh this relates to the question
I asked about this, this is,
relates to the priority question we had
about who signed it and who didn't sign it.
So they kept on revealing new layers
of meaning in their study of Pilgrims
and the Pilgrims entry into the area.
And the whole history of the exchange
by having done that work originally
with the Question Formulation Technique.
So let's look at this eighth
grade, sixth grade history example
where Megan Harvel was introducing
a unit on the Civil War.
And she was about to give them a reading,
but before she gave them a reading
that they would start learning about the topic,
this is the question focus that she used.
All right.
So what, what are sixth graders going
to ask when they look at this photo?
Why are they fighting?
Are they fighting?
Where were they?
What started the fight?
Who are they?
Were they signing anything?
Who else was there?
Why are you hitting him?
It's a great middle school question.
Why didn't they call 911?
And then right after that they
asked, was this related to slavery?
And they went all the way through,
including getting to number 15,
which is another middle school
question, who hit who first?
But then the questions, number 17, who
died, and number 18, why are they smiling?
And that why are they smiling is very
significant because it shows a level
of attention to a primary source that is
really significant, because it's something
that probably many of us might have missed.
But what does it mean that those men
in the background there are smiling?
And they asked that question.
They got to that question,
at question number 18.
So it shows you the level of attention that,
that and the ability to analyze primary sources
that students are able to do, if given
the opportunity to ask questions.
Now Andrew's going to share with you an
example from a high school history class.
>> Hi everyone.
So this is another example from Kelly Grotrian,
an 11th grade US history teacher
from East Brunswick, New Jersey.
Students were beginning to learn about the
end of World War II, and she used the QFT
so students were actually generating their
own questions ahead of the discussion.
And the discussion was going
to be centered around the,
the question whether the US was
justified in dropping the Atomic Bomb.
And students were also going
to use the same questions
for a homework assignment via Google classroom.
And so here was the question focus that
Kelly presented to her 11th grade students.
And here are some of the
questions that they asked.
Students began by asking, what is this?
And then the second question, who did this?
Students quickly moved into
inquiring about the impact
of the event depicted in the primary source.
How did this affect people?
And question four, what were the environmental
and economic implications of dropping the bomb?
In question six, you can see a student makes
a very interesting and nuanced observation
of something in the lower right hand corner.
Is that a plane wing in the bottom right?
This prompts the next student question,
did the people in that plane drop the bomb?
And question eight, an ethical question,
did the people dropping the
bomb know what they were doing?
And question ten, a student asks, who
was responsible for dropping the bomb?
Then to question 11, a question
about cause, what led to this event?
And question 12, a question about a fact, what
happened as a result of dropping this bomb?
Students questions about cause and effect
including effects like that mentioned
in question 17, where a student asks, how many
lives were lost as a result, simulated this type
of student thinking that Kelly was
trying to get from the students.
And it led direct, directly to where
she was planning for the lesson to go,
to have them start thinking about whether the
US was justified in dropping the atomic bombs.
Now that you've seen some of, some examples
from Maureen Bennett in an elementary class,
Megan Harvel from a middle school class,
and Kelly Grotrian from a high school class,
I'd like to invite all of you to
share how can the QFT be helpful
when using primary sources in your classroom.
So if you all want to take a minute and
share now that you've seen those examples,
how you can use the QFT for
teaching primary sources.
And so we've learned a lot about how teachers
are using the Question Formulation Technique
in their classroom, and in our article which
Dan mentioned earlier, Making Questions Flow,
we discuss how it can be used
to stimulate student interest
and engagement at the beginning of a lesson.
Just as Megan Harvel did
with the [inaudible] example.
It can be used to impart knowledge and
help start, students start thinking
about the information of a heavy text
of a, of a historical test, text,
such as the Mayflower compact
in Maureen Bennett's example.
Educators have begun to use students questions
to be better understand what
students know or do not know.
And teachers and librarians and educators all
have also used the QFT as a summit of assessment
to kick off a research project or
paper, or in Joshua Beers' example,
actually using the students questions as a
part of a final exam on a unit on Imperialism.
>> This is Dan again.
I'd like to thank you Andrew for that
really good example and analysis.
I, I'd like to share with you some of what
we are learning from teachers in the field
and their use of the Question
Formulation Technique.
And they have looked at what happens when
they teach the three thinking abilities.
And see that, that becomes something
that they had not necessarily
been aware before they wanted
to deliberately teach those abilities,
but as they see students develop them
through using the Question
Formulation Technique,
they've come to understand how significant
it is for students to acquire those abilities
and they begin to deliberately
foster opportunities for them
to practice those thinking abilities.
So those teaching of the three thinking
abilities actually now becomes a pedagogy.
It becomes a distinct, deliberate way to
help your students develop intellectually.
Now when students are using the three thinking
abilities something else is happening.
It's actually a theory of learning.
Because if you think about it, if
you observe students in classroom
and you see them doing divergent thinking,
you see them do convergent thinking,
and you see them doing metacognitive
thinking, each one of which has been,
has been a great challenge to promote
in many different environments.
And you see them easily move through
those thinking abilities, develop them,
become more expert at using them, you really
begin to see this becomes an explanation
of how students are learning by
using these three thinking abilities.
So let's, I'm just going to share with you
starting off some final words that we have
about putting students minds into motion.
>> Thank you for that Dan.
So the name of the session, Questions
are the Engines of Intellect,
How to Simulate Student Curiosity and Questions.
It's actually derived from a quote by
famed historian David Hackett Fisher.
And he said, questions are the engines
of intellect, the cerebral machines
which convert energy to motion, and
curiosity to controlled inquiry.
And now in the year 2015, what do students
who learn how to ask their own questions say?
Well an eighth grade student from Austin,
Texas, in James Bursar's history class reported
that the QFT helps me by getting me
to think about questions on my own.
Also it gets my mind in motion, to think
about the questions other people make.
>> Thank you Andrew.
That's, that's quite a quote there.
And to think about how it connects to
David Hackett Ficker's, Fisher's quote,
and the title of this whole webinar, The
Engine, the Questions are the Engines
of the Intellect is really
quite, quite remarkable.
So let's think for a moment about, in this age
of Google where you know students have access
to quick answers, and they, in some ways, think
that getting information is relatively easy
because they can simply Google it, let's
look about, let's look at that idea
of the role of technology and learning.
Clive Thompson, a really clever technology
journalist has written a great book called
Smarter Than You Think, How Technology
is Changing Our Minds for the Better.
And he talked about how, since students,
everybody has such access to information
and in the age of Google there's so much,
so many resources available for
quickly finding information.
He said, well how should you respond when you
get powerful new tools for finding answers?
And he concludes his entire book by
saying, think of harder questions.
So let's look at the skill of asking questions.
The importance of the skill of asking
questions is certainly for moving from ignorance
to knowledge, for arriving at better answers,
for increasing engagement and ownership.
But it's for more as well.
You can demonstrate inquiry in the classroom,
and you can generate a little more joy
for teachers in a very demanding profession
as their students discover the joy
of asking questions and setting
a learning agenda.
And then there's another reason, which is
certainly relevant to the convener and,
of this entire conference and our
webinar, the Library of Congress.
It's connected to democracy.
And if you look at this picture, and at the
center of this picture you can see Septima Clark
who is a teacher in the Charleston,
South Carolina School system.
And after 18 years, in 1955, she was
fired for being a member of the NAACP.
So Septima and her cousin Bernice Robinson,
who's standing behind her, a beautician,
set up what they called Citizenship Schools
to teach basic literacy to adults in the area.
And Septima Clark did it not just
because she wanted to make sure
that they could prevent themselves from
being, from being cheated out of wages and,
and she wanted to be sure they could
help themselves in various ways,
but she also saw it as part
of the larger project.
She saw it for, in connection to democracy.
She said, we need to be taught
to study rather than to believe,
to inquire rather than to affirm, affirm.
So what Septima Clark managed to do
is capture in a sense the real power
of teaching students ask their own questions.
You're building citizens of the
future, you're creating students
who can become self-directed learners and who
will discover new things just as that student
in California said, just when you think
you've asked everything you need to ask,
you discover a new question to ask,
and it opens up whole new worlds.
And those are the questions that are awaiting us
when students learn how to
ask their own questions.
And I, I'd like you to, to, to know that we
have pushed you quickly through this process.
We are very grateful to the Library of
Congress and teaching the primary sources
for this opportunity to share the
Question Formulation Technique with you.
It was meant to give you a taste of it,
and a glimpse of how it can
be used with primary sources.
And it's great to see Mary
Johnson on this, on the webinar,
because she really helped
get the whole ball rolling
in introducing the Question
Formulation Technique
through the entire great network
of teaching the primary sources.
So there are more resources on
our website at RightQuestion.org.
There are more videos.
You can watch the full video
that you say the trailer from.
And there are videos of different
age levels, different subject areas.
And we also invite you to help us
promote the idea of students learning
to ask their own questions, of helping
build the democracy with citizens
who are asking questions, and to be
part of the million classrooms campaign.
>> I want to thank Dan and Andrew for a
wonderful presentation and very inspiring,
and thanks to everybody who
attended the session.